technology doesn't help much and I don't
I don't disagree I mean I think that's
that is a hundred percent true
however I also think that you know in a
marriage you know I mean Hannah would
like to think her dad's perfect he's not
I'm not like it's not a perfect marriage
for sure however we have you know a bump
in the road here and there every time
you go through a different relationship
you have another bump in a road except
it's like a mountain and so why not be
in a situation where you are evolving
and growing and evolving and growing
together and I can tell you that our
relationship started out in a really
horrible place